it is great being here and it's very
appropriate that we've all assembled
here to focus on the research that
Carnegie Mellon is doing with robotics
and it goes back to the great phrase
that founded this institution coming out
of Andrew Carnegie and that Jerry
referred to and how about Jerry without
a tie I mean is that freaking rocking or
what yeah my heart is in the work if
you've studied Slavic languages like I
have
you will know that the word for work in
Russian and other Slavic languages is
rubato
so basically Andrew Carnegie was saying
my heart is in the robot
now think about the visionary approach
that was a hundred years ago and already
he knew where we were heading so this
evening is a celebration it's a
celebration of the work that we have
been doing in robotics and how that work
is a manifestation of Andrew Carnegie's
phrase because the other part of his
phrase is my heart so we've got the
heart and the robot and what do we have
there we've got the personification of
the right-brain left-brain coming
together that marks our University
unlike any other University and we have
put together a panel that represents
that cross-section it is my pleasure to
invite them up to the stage by the way
when you saw that Carnegie Mellon sign
that is has recently been erected on
Mount Washington we figured why should
Hollywood have all the fun you know how
at night they come to the fence well we
tore down the Alcoa sign we put up
Carnegie Mellon so let's get this party
started it is my pleasure to introduce
to the stage 31 years means glasses Jody
for Liese an associate professor from
human-computer interaction Institute and
the school of design Jody come on up and
the Paisano Daniel Wilson a multiple
alumnus and author of how to survive a
robot uprising and most recently
robopocalypse which is soon to be a
Steven Spielberg film Daniel
and a fellow New Yorker how we chose it
a professor in the robotics Institute at
Carnegie Mellon Howie let's give all
three we've invited all of you here
because the work that you're doing is
really indicative of what's going on at
Carnegie Mellon University but also the
zeitgeist of really our society and so I
want to start with human-computer
interaction because increasingly I think
it probably should be renamed computer
human interaction because these
computers are now getting to the point
where their ability to interact with us
to be proactive to really become
companions is growing and that's a lot
of the work that you're doing so Jodie
tell us about this well done that's
right my research group studies the
social aspects of Technology and because
I'm a designer instead of evaluating
technology that already exists I can
work with robot assists and computer
scientists to imagine the future to
design build and evaluate these systems
and let me tell you we have learned some
fascinating things about robots that
work closely with people so my research
group designed a robot called snack bot
I think you're gonna see a picture here
maybe there he is and snack bot is
designed to allow us to study human
robot interaction over the long term and
it delivers snacks and our university
buildings providing a useful long-term
service let's roll a video snack-bot at
work
I have an order for Kathy
please take your cookie Thanks can be
enjoying her snack I hope you have a
wonderful day
goodbye so we recently ran a long-term
study of people ordering snacks that
snack-bot delivered and we varied the
design of the robot with social and
personalization behaviors in the social
behaviors the robot chatted with people
about things that the organization knew
about like carnival in the
personalization condition it would do
things like remember what kind of snacks
who took offered to do a stretch with
you or bring you a special personalized
snack and we found that personalization
increased people's rapport and
engagement with the robot so this is a
robot that delivers snacks
okay there's more to it than this I mean
how is this robot able to deliver snacks
and what kind of snacks does it deliver
well one interesting thing is that the
robot brought fruit and healthy snacks
but also candy bars and cookies and we
found that people would maybe change
their behavior if a robot knew that they
had a cookie every Friday it might
inspire them to make healthy choices we
also learned that the reality of robots
working in the real world as they break
down and that robots need to gracefully
recover from these breakdowns for
example Don did you know that people
like it when a robot apologizes they
trust a robot more after it breaks down
and apologizes that's another thing that
we learned well that that's gotten me
very far in life too especially with the
ladies so robots I mean people like it
when robots apologize yes they do they
have to do anything wrong this is like
that old joke if a man speaks in the
forest and there's no woman there to
hear him is he still wrong well the
answer to that is yes but by and large
people want to have a social experience
a positive social experience with this
technology only a few people really are
looking for maximum value in the time if
they interact and so collectively we can
take what we learn about these features
in human robot interaction and apply
them in other situations such as
designing robots and hospitals and
robots to assist the elderly and people
with disabilities ok let's get back to
that because that is a very genuine
practical application I mean I can
imagine if I'm really in a senior
citizen home those snacks are going to
become really important it's Daniel
Daniel you have been focused on let's
say science fiction science faction I
mean as you're there writing and you
look at the world around us I mean we're
surrounded by robots on the stage dating
from the 40s from the 50s I mean
what's the connection I mean how does
science-fiction become science faction
well I think first of all that all the
advances that have been happening in
robotics at Carnegie Mellon and other
places are making it really hard to
write more science fiction because I
mean it's just basically it used to be
that science fiction pretty much
dominated the public perception of what
a robot was you know before the 1950s
there were no robots there was all these
guys in rubber suits you know and that
was a robot in fact when the first robot
started showing up and then in the
mid-1950s there was the UNAM eight
industrial robotic arm and they tried to
sell that to General Motors and General
Motors was so scared of the public
perception of robots that they only
agreed to test it in a in secret in a
laboratory you know and then of course
they followed that up by not buying it
and I think that's because before you
had Wolfman and the mummy and then you
had robots from outer space and so you
know even now I think that science
fiction really the term robotic for
instance means to move with a jerky
shaky gait you know and that's not
because that's how robots move you know
if you look at big dog I can I think
you've got a video to show if you look
at the big dog robot here it's moving
like an animal and this is kind of a
longer video so at some point someone's
gonna kick this guy and oh here we go
and when you see that that's not the
definition of the word robotic you know
so science fact is catching up and I
think it's starting to push science
fiction further because you know that's
definitely actually I've seen a video
where it's two guys facing each other
and tights walking backwards and so a
guy in a rubber suit could technically
do that but that you know that's not it
so and and then also the staples of
science fiction are already here
you know robot Butler's artificial
intelligence that you can talk to on
your phone and it will do stuff for you
that's Siri it's all already here so you
know if the goal of a scientist is to
stand on the shoulders of giants and the
goal of a science fiction author is to
stand on the shoulders of giants and
then leap off into the unknown
I think that we writers have a lot of
leaping to do actually by the way I do
want to clarify there are not people in
these robots here so we're not violating
an earth rules or or anything like that
okay so we just saw a slide of a big dog
bad dog where do you get your
inspiration I mean are used like sitting
there staring at YouTube or you know
like looking through Department of
Defense of manuals I mean we're just
I do both of those things did you know
if you want to know what's what it
sounds like when somebody gets Joe
choked unconscious YouTube right there
anything you need you can find it and
you could write about fun fact and no
until you know you don't have to look
far to find inspiration you know I'm
inspired by the real world interactions
that people have with all technology and
and I think that creating tools and tool
building is the hallmark of humanity I
mean that is what defines our species
it's what's important about us the very
first people were building tools we
build tools people in the future are
going to build tools and there's this
whole trajectory to humankind and it's
really fun to actually build the future
as some people do it's also a really fun
to try to figure out where we're going
and how we're gonna get there and what
it's going to look like when we get
there
so I think fact and fiction have both
got parts to play there and it's a great
time to be thinking about this stuff
because we live in a world where a 20
year old kid in a you know college dorm
can come up with a some internet idea
and fundamentally change how hundreds of
millions of people interact socially and
do it in a couple of years and so the
scope of technical technological change
and the rate of change are just
unprecedented you know and so there's
inspiration all around us for that we're
gonna come back to that because
obviously I want to talk about the movie
and and some of your views on that but I
want to go to how we now how we if we
look around the stage we've got the
original Gort from the 1941 dynamic
doctor Satan
we've got target earth road
from 1954 we've got tobor robot spelled
backwards for those of you from the 1954
movie tobor they're great and of course
we've got Gork from The Day the Earth
Stood Still 1951 but all of them are
truly anthropomorphic I mean they they
look like people that looked like actors
wearing suits in terms of shapes is this
what we're looking at for robots or or
what so the animal kingdom is full of
examples of morphologies different
shapes that are uniquely qualified for
the kinds of tasks that these animals
must perform so my group we work on
snake robots so just like biological
snakes these robots can thread through a
tightly packed volumes and get to
locations that people and machinery
otherwise can't access or at least not
access to easily so one application that
we're working on it's very near and dear
to my heart is urban search-and-rescue
these robots can serve as tools that can
extend the reach of rescue workers and
locate victims and collapsed structures
in this first you know 48 hours very
critical time that we locate these
people recently about a year ago we
actually started another application
it's it's archeology you know going into
confined spaces we do this in Egypt just
before the Revolution started except
archeology is like search and rescue but
there's no rush because everyone's been
dead for 5000 yes and you know with
these robots we're also able to actually
I brought some with me if you want to
see them you have a demonstration robot
yeah okay you want me to come please
come you thought we weren't here's
audience okay so we should have one of
these robots here you can see it moves
like a snake yes it looks like a snake
so it has all these joints these
internal degrees of freedom and this
robot what makes it special is not only
shape but it can go places that wheeled
vehicles otherwise can't access not only
that it can swim breach through fences
go in pipes go through ducts
it could even climb
fools climb the inside of pipes and you
can get to places that machines you know
typically otherwise wouldn't or may not
want to go
so here the stencil is this is not gonna
hurt no no that this is fine you're a
little tense I'm straddling your snake
well I thought this was PG we don't oh
whoa whoa ah finally it took till I was
58 and a half for this to happen
so is this the first time at robots
touched you there yes and you can walk
with it this is really cool
so I mean does this have like an
application for me like it oh-ho-ho so
this robot could hurt you
it's not our intention and let us know
if it does he hurt but but there are
other things we can do so the eskimos of
this phrase is like twenty-eight kinds
of snow whereas for us at least on the
east coast is snow and slush la I don't
know what you call it I don't know if
you have it but there's other kinds of
snake robots and one of them that were
developing is a small snake robots for a
minimally invasive surgery so with these
devices in a sense we're doing minimally
invasive surgery on our structure if you
shake it down you can do real minimally
invasive surgery and we're not going to
do a demo of that right now you don't
have like the kidney stone searching
robot dude no no all right so what we
have here in the video actually is uh is
one of our snake robots it's one
centimeter in diameter and this is we
your pittsburgh's also very unique that
we have world-class medicine at that
other school and world-class robotics at
Carnegie Mellon and putting the two
together we've been able to make these
nice medical devices medical robots here
what we're doing is we're doing a heart
operation and I should point out this is
on a human person this is a first in
human procedure so nowhere so in five
years from concept coming up the concept
of actually operation and what we're
doing is is what wrapping around a
woman's heart doing an epicardial
ablation
and what you see in this video here is
the images from the front of the snake
robots the white is her lungs the
pericardium is transparent and that us
on the left is the heart beating the
image is a lot better actually but we
lost some resolution when I can press
the MPEG but the idea is she was able to
get this epicardial of mapping without
having her chest cracked open and a
procedure which would take I don't know
10 11 months to you know fully recover
from she went home the next day from the
hospital without any complications okay
that Beckett's a round of applause I'm
really glad I had carpaccio for dinner
too okay let's open it up to all of you
Daniel your new movie is called
robopocalypse now I've heard the word
pocalypse used before and it's not good
so tell me about this I mean obviously
three of the four robots that are on the
stage here by the way Fred Barton
brought us the robots Freddie shout out
three or four of these robots kind of
were terrified
they were scaring us yeah I mean what's
happening in robopocalypse I'm following
in a long law exactly what sounds like
is happening action robopocalypse mmm
it's just a couple of boy and the robot
yeah ya know so it's it's a near-term
future and it's a it's a story of the
technology that we're familiar with
basically not working anymore and
deciding to try to kill us that's the
quick version but it does follow in a
long line of stories that are similar i
I wanted people to know what was going
on right from reading the cover and then
once I've got you in that's what I write
I start going in different directions
but you know what I really think this is
about the reason that we have so many of
these types of stories where it's you
know a little bit maybe it you can think
of as a negative portrayal of technology
is that I think that we have all got a
love-hate relationship with technology
I mean we get more of it every day we
depend on it more it does more and more
amazing things for us and then we depend
on it more and then that's scary and
it's kind of terrifying and so kind of
the simplest thing to do with a story is
you just externalize that love-hate
relationship that you have into a form
that's really easy to focus on and shoot
a gun at and run away from and I'm
talking about the killer robot you know
that's why we've we've had killer robots
forever you know well I do think it's
essential that we have that but going
back to like you know that my heart is
in the work my heart is in the robot I
mean how we you were just talking about
the snake robot being miniaturized to
the point where it has medical
application which is extremely I mean
I'd rather have the snake robot than the
zipper job I mean anytime but there Jody
users you're talking about robots that
become social companions that are that
are helping us I mean so you know
Carnegie Mellon we we inject that the
human side into the robots as well yeah
I joined the dark side basically and
broke but you know I could say that
dystopian scenarios are really great to
give us a fate that we'd like to avoid
and you can say in utopian scenarios
give us a place to something to strive
for I could say that roboticists and
scientists are clearly smart enough to
pick and choose the to be inspired by
you know specific details and not get
wrapped up in whether or not the robots
trying to kill somebody or not but I
think at the end of the day the reason
that you know I wrote robopocalypse the
way I did it and the reason that we have
so many killer robots is that it's fun
it's a good still destroy the earth
planet bond it's dramatic I mean you
have these life-or-death stakes and
these robots are are you know are really
fighting people all the way to the death
you know and so I'm just gonna check my
cheat sheet here while you're checking
so Jody to tell us more about the human
side about the companion well I will say
that the world is definitely influenced
by robots they've seen in
cinema science-fiction and so part of
the work of people who are designing for
the real world is to help work with the
expectations of people so even when
things have something that's a tiny bit
social like a floor cleaning vacuum
people want to anthropomorphize it
socialize it give it names you know have
reasons for why it behaves the way it
does and so we need to design very
carefully to work within that landmine
if you will yeah when you talked about
robots breaking down so much I was
thinking they it would really work out
here in LA you know we should set up
like a satellite campus here so what I
mean what other work is going on with
robots interfacing with with children
with people well there's definitely
researched with robots helping autistic
children we have research with robots
helping elders and their caregivers to
keep people staying more independently
in their homes longer we are working
with robots that fetch and carry to
bring and help people with disabilities
who may not be able to walk or use their
mobility in ways that we do so the field
is spreading and the applications are
many many many are happening at CMU so
how we you're doing a lot of work on
medical robots is the idea to replace
doctors I mean is this the doctors best
friend what so the yes they still going
to get a bill what was it so as Daniel
brought up there's this love-hate
relationship with technology and with
medical robots first and foremost what's
most important is that it improves
patient care so it's less pain to people
in a hospital a lot less time the costs
go down that's the most important thing
but what's happening especially with
medical robots is that physicians who
don't have access to medical resources
at centers of medical excellence
perhaps positions who have less training
they're able to do procedures that in
the past surgeons would have done so now
we're democratizing medical care we're
offloading the responsibility from
surgeons what this has is this
interesting side effect that now that
more
local care is being delivered it's
actually creating jobs because now more
people can deliver medical care
so we're disseminating creating jobs
it's all the good things